hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zur
vierten ausgabe vom werbe die haben den
erzeuger special
hier ist er gastgeber was die apple
hallo auch nicht begrüßt auch direkt
unseren heutigen gast kommt crafter
moment hallo ich will da sind die
falsche richtung gelaufen ist sehr gut
aber ich hätte mich einfach mal wieder
so cool drauf wetten dass sei oder wie
49 habe das schild ist weg ja hallo herr
wunder regieren unsere wunderschöne
architektur hier ein wenig renoviert
seit dem letzten besuch beim letzten
besuch das bestimmt ein halbes jahr
ach du das ist schon das können schon ja
sein ja klar über ein halbes jahr auf
alle fälle also das format gibt es jetzt
ungefähr seit einem jahr ja dass auf
jeden fall über normal bewegt sondern
diesmal treffe ich das schild
es gibt aber lasst das schild bitte wie
vielen dank so bei mir anfangen oder hat
nämlich letzten worte meine letzten
worte ist jetzt eine todesurkunde
richtig ich hoffe natürlich dass ich mal
wieder alles aus dem rahmen sprengen
kann hier und denke das wird mir zwar
nicht gelinge aber ich hoffe einfach auf
dem faires spiel
und ja gut fangen wir direkt mal mit
fragen um eur 1 es geht um 50 diamanten
und die frage kommt von hohlkopf king 1
von dem kopf ging ein jahr von dem heute
sehr sehr viele fans sehr viel
eingesendet sehr viel brauchbares und
sie lautet wie hieß quoten kandels alter
kanal netzkabel bkw model c der kabel
oder de cartel media sicher das ist
nicht der fall ist
ich weiß wer ich bin ich bin für den ok
das ist natürlich richtig du kam wie aus
der pistole geschossen ich total
vergessen dass man die
auswahlmöglichkeiten hat ich hab einfach
direkt die lösung gesagt ja das
vergessen viele fahren zu verzeichnen
personen ja gut mache weiter mit fragen
um eur 2 es geht um 100 jemanden und
auch diese frage kommt von hohlkopf king
1 und sie lautet mit welchem verfahren
aktuell einige youtuber durch die gegend
longboards b skateboards oder die
scooter güterweg unterwegs im auto
scooter so durchgehend fahren aber ich
glaube ich bin für longboards es ist
mittlerweile sind trendige heuer das ist
auch richtig dass auch 10
da liege ich richtig ja ich habe einst
geschenkt bekommen von einem freund
damals das war sein erstes ist schon
zwei jahre alt aber das ist nicht mein
eigenes ich wollte einen penny bord
kaufen
wahrscheinlich aber damit noch weniger
unterwegs sein kann london ist aber dass
ein bisschen sperrig aber so ein handy
bord ist also halb groß wie solon bord
und da hab ich gedacht dass ich mir
sowas vielleicht mal hole aber kostet
das kostet auch so viel das kostet 100
euro sonntag so krass longboard ist ist
auch richtig der portokasse jahr lang
bot ist recht perfekt gut machen wir
weiter mit fragen um eur 3 es geht um
250 diamanten und die frage lautet was
sind die minecraft riems maps gebaut von
mojang maps gebaut von bojan so b eine
spezielle version von minecraft c server
von mojang oder die leuchtenden super
blöcke auf jeden fall ist es auch oder c
also es ist auf jeden fall von mojang
und da würde ich jetzt spannung rein
bringen würde ich sagen
krasses spannung ist aber richtig ja
weil es wie ich mit nach unserem
minecraft reality drin ich hab das bei
mir menü immer ich bin einmal drauf
gegangen und da habe ich mir da jetzt
gerade auch gedacht
das kann eigentlich keine map von mojang
sein weil das war eine ganz normale
generierte welt oder man so ein paar
blöcke gesetzt ihr also das sind wohl
einfach minecraft server von mojang
wurzel wahrscheinlich seinem eingeladen
von einem zuschauer hörer keine ahnung
wie das funktioniert ich habe da auch
noch nie drauf gespielt und alles also
keine ahnung ja dann wie gesagt am
wasser einfach nur ein gelder an gut ja
da machen wir weiter mit fragen wo 4
es geht um 500 diamanten und die frage
lautet zu welcher minecraft version sind
die aktuellsten pre release is a 1.17 b
1.11 10.12 oder de 1.8 doch mal bitte
die die auswahlmöglichkeiten 17 c a
sowie das sind die 17 11 17 12 und 1.8
das sind nicht die snap shops gemeint
sondern die heißen pre release so wie es
damals also ich war der einzige neue
zeit gibt es ja die zurzeit gibt es ja
die version 1.7 punkt 4
und ich weiß dass diese pre release also
ich weiß nicht ich glaube der neuesten
irgendwie 10 7.10
und die sind die geniale ich verstehe
die frage jetzt nicht so ganz also ich
weiß es der neueste release ist glaube
ich 1.7 punkt 10
und die gehen alle auf die 1.8 zu ja es
ist nach dem aktuellen release gefragt
so also da würde ich sagen ich bin ich
sicher was war nur die auffälligkeiten
widersteht ich bin ich gucke die 10 17
11 10 12 und 18
1 11 12 8 jahre das ist gerade eben
mehrfach gesagt ja ich weiß dass es zehn
ist also ich bin mir ich bezahle es die
letzte nicht gespielt habe das war vor
einer woche ca ich weiß nicht ob schon
wieder raus gekommen ist ich würde es
einfach mal sagen zehn von elf und zwölf
nichts mitbekommen hab ja das ist
richtig ist es 10
ich versteh ich dachte man die kommt
wesentlich an die das waren die cftc /
release ist die cham ist einfach mal
wieder so die gab es auch nicht zu 1 6
oder so okay da hat sich mal vor man so
gedacht ach ja kaum war sie mal als
punkt sieben jahren 15.10 und alle sehr
richtig ja super
ja gut machen wir weiter mit fragen im
raw 5 es ist keine sicherung stufe beim
special
es geht um 1000 diamanten und die frage
kommt von pauli wo und sie lautet welche
spiel welches spiel gab es vor kurzem
bei origin aufs haus medal of honor sims
3 c battlefield 3 oder der need for
speed most wanted bsc gesagt ja das ist
richtig das hat air china syndrom
aufgeregt ich hab mir vor drei wochen
oder vor vier wochen habe ich mir
battlefield 3 da gekauft weil ich dachte
als relativ günstig kaufe ich mir mal
eine woche später das komplett umsonst
ich mich so aufgeregt noch es ist zwar
wirklich die das spiel damals gekostet
hat aber trotzdem irgendwie also ich
nicht so aufgeregt ist er ja ja gut
machen wir direkt mal weiter mit fragen
06 es geht um 2.500 diamanten
hoffen wir mal das ist schon mitbekommen
hast und zwar geht es nämlich darum mit
wem cola kollaborierte sei bei seinem
neuesten song
wird ihnen verfolgt ließ einfach vorher
lehne fischer bsu block c eminem oder
die madonna auf keinen fall
ich will nie einsetzen was wusste
einsetzen was aber das ist immer so ein
bisschen aussetzer ja das ist weil mein
internet bisschen kacke ich weiß nicht
ich würde am liebsten den joker
einsetzen aber ich bin mir auch gerade
irgendwie gar nicht so sicher also auf
jeden fall auf keinen fall kann ich
diesen 50 50 joker einsetzen
anna hazare aber kein joker männer so
nachdem nach dem 10 fr habe ich danach
dann kein joker männer generell hast du
dann keinen mehr menschen einsetzt so
generell gar kein narr ich mal ganz
einfach ein ausschlussverfahren
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher bei
dieser scheiße wieder da michael
fischer-art im moment ich möchte einfach
probieren
helene fischer ist es auf keinen fall
weil helene fischer ist eine die macht
glaube ich weil die gar keine cola boss
aber diese auf deutsch die wird ja die
kontaktsuche was wäre auch schon von der
was noch madonna ich glaube ich auch
nicht ich glaube nicht dass da was mit
madonna macht weil madonna einfach eine
komplett andere richtung was wär was
noch wer waren die anderen beiden snoop
dogg und m
was und bauch raus hätte ich jetzt
eigentlich als eminem gesagt aber eminem
hat jetzt gerade wieder neues album
rausgebracht dieses marshall blabla als
zwei irgendwas ja irgendwie sowas war
das um 12 in kleinen tipp kick
ich wollte dir nur sagen was fenster
vielleicht am verrücktesten so als kombi
so was man nicht unbedingt erwartet
hätte womit ein koreaner so musik macht
ihr am verrücktesten wendig snoop dogg
aber das ist gerade weil es ein
verrücktes brüssel sagen ich würde jetzt
überhaupt nicht sicher ich will
eigentlich keinen job kopfprämie 30 der
mhh warum würde ich wohl nach den
verrücktesten fragen nicht damit hinaus
schließt ja da sage ich ich hätte jetzt
beim ausschuss war fand ich echt gesagt
auf jeden fall keine frau auf jeden fall
eminem oder snoop dogg und entweder man
karten neues album raus gehauen aber da
ich hätte eher gedacht dass so etwas mit
eminem macht als mit snoop dogg der
eltern hat er ganz neues album und ich
weiß wie heißt das lied hangover gibt
sich schon hangover liegt ja von taio
cruz aber auch hangover getauft es war
schön heute manchmal ja gut wenn welche
fragen sind jetzt jetzt kommt frage
sieben von 15
es geht um 5.000 diamanten und die frage
lautet was soll am 16 06 2014
stattfinden das wäre übrigens jetzt zur
aufnahme heute in die aa die entfernung
der bewertungsfunktion schließung von
hfc verkauf von myvideo oder die
löschung inaktive abonnenten
ich sagte erst sobald es darauf hinaus
dass heute deutschland gegen portugal
spielt aber jetzt würde ich sagen
die löschung von inaktiven abonnenten wo
also habe ich mir relativ sicher sehr
sehr sicher
aber ich bin mir kann man machen die das
um welche uhrzeit immer noch irgendwie
uhrzeit also bei mir auch noch nicht
passiert falls du darauf hinaus willst
noch ist es passiert also ich bin ich es
bleibt spannend
es wird auf jeden fall witzig ich möchte
wird das men
wer richtig viel entfernt wird das finde
ich richtig cool weil das netz für die
abo zahl wieder total wer sehr geringer
aber da wirst dich wirklich wie viele
wirklich dabei sind ja das finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool ich glaube juli
werden auch richtig viel entfernt weil
dann schon so lange dabei ist aber egal
die auf jeden fall ist richtig ja so
machen weiter mit fragen um macht es
geht um 8.000 jemanden die frage kommen
wieder von unserem heißgeliebten
hohlkopf king 1 und sie lautet wer
verließ als erster das megaprojekt jetzt
heißt es zurückdenken prime games brdc
look place oder de broadcast tv oder
luke place was es war
wo all das ist aber schwierig wie brot
sagen lu place der hat damals nach ein
paar folgen schon gesagt jene blabla
kann ich dich von der zeit her
veronique auf keinen fall der hat erst
das ist ganz am ende gesagt nachdem die
sogar dieser sache da geplant haben dann
gab es da noch brocken stars mit ihm
habe ich noch ganz am ende aufgenommen
ich will ja luke play platz für zu sagen
hast du das
ja ich war echt nicht sicher wann ist
das war aber relativ klein ist er dann
auch relativ zeitnah ausgetretene ja da
lag ich doch schon etwas mehr zeit
dazwischen
ja aber auf jeden fall die reihenfolge
war hat glaube ich keinen sinn 20 folgen
gemacht
die reihenfolge auf ihren flug dann zu
treiben
dann drohten form sondern zur uni oder
zur rolle und trockenes am tor ist egal
eine handlung auf jeden fall besser erst
gut
darum ging es ja auch ne machen wir
weiter mit fragen um 9 es geht um 16.000
diamanten und die frage lautet wo fand
der dvd 2014 statt
war es aber in köln b in münchen c in
hamburg oder dem berlin
ich bin total durcheinander gekommen vom
web video preis dem dvd also der video
preis in düsseldorf aber der die
wiederwahl in berlin also die war das
glaube ich das ist richtig weil habe ich
super toll ausgesehen von levi und von
maxima von leuchten ruppelt und malte
auch und alle altes ich war besonders
der wahl von einer ganz besonderen
sekunden max hat auch ein gemacht
ich studiere da sicher ja max hat einen
gemacht glaube ich weiß dass leute das
fein gemacht hat aber von krankhafter
oder etwa also ich hab mich da einfach
vertan
alles egal ob davon gesehen so ja berlin
basketball so machen wird im freien die
letzte bei der du kein joker verwenden
darfst und ich muss dazu sagen die frage
von ursprünglich für supreme noch
konzipiert und da du drin bist könnte
das ein wenig erleichtern und zwar fragt
19 es geht um 32.000 diamanten und die
frage lautet wer ist in galaxy
ungespielt begum hdc herr bergmann oder
dgl pvp und das ist richtig gut
ja damit darf ab jetzt alle joker
verwenden sie sind nun bekannt gegeben
es kommt noch fünf fragen drei joker
also ein bisschen leichter machen wir
direkt weiter mit fragen um roh 11 es
geht um 65.000 diamanten und die frage
kommen vorn rat macht wohl king hohlkopf
kontinente sich herum und die frage
lautet wie heißt der server von weiß
weiß kürzlich eröffnet und es geht auch
ein wenig um die ip davon a base punkt
net.de weiss was.de playboy.de oder die
eu punkte wave.com ich nehme auf jeden
fall york habe ich überlegt welchen ich
bin ich glaube ich habe ich glaube steht
einfach in weiß weiß barner drin also
falls kein 50 50 enten willst mir im
internet auch ganz einfach ich nehme in
deiner jogger ja dann schon nach also
ich glaube es weiß barner drin
ich werde mein herz drin ich nehme theys
punkt net das ging schnell
das ist richtig gutes internet merkt ja
merke ich genau wollte sich ungefähr so
an gutes internet wächst ja das ist
richtig ist auch angekommen
da wirst du perfekt so jetzt wird es
noch ein wenig kniffliger es geht
umfragen um 12 auf dem spiel stehen
125000 diamanten und die frage lautet
was ist keine verzauberung für ein
schwert
dazu sei gesagt es geht natürlich reine
keine verzögerung für ein schwert ja ok
es kann eventuell über ein zauberbuch
über einen amboss übertragen werden aber
es geht wirklich nur mehr in chapman
table
und dabei geht es um plünderungen schlag
10 oder dms ist gliederfüßer dass ich
mal wieder ausgeschrieben wird man ja
sag mal bitte nochmal plünderung
schlagmann normal rate okay das war's
keine verzauberung für ein schwert ja
das gibt heute warte mal ganz kurz nähe
ich nehme gerade auf mein gott der
weisheit der hengst extra so ein schild
an der tür aufnahme in das ferne
kartoffelsalat jetzt rede ich habe
weggeschickt nochmals die sachen wie
blinde schlag bann und nahm es ist der
gliederfüßer also eine minister guido
fischer ist doch dieses das ist bestimmt
dieses petroplus besitzt heißt
eigentlich immer besser deswegen das
habe ich auf jeden fall schon mal
gesehen weil ich das in faro richtig oft
auf meinem schwer druck hat und ich das
nie braucht ja so was gab es noch bands
weit das gibt auf jeden fall auch was
waren die anderen länder und schlag habe
ich ehrlich gesagt nie gehörter kenne
ich nur schärfe noch und rückstoß glaube
ich ich weiß nicht ob eines davon schlag
ist aber dieses mal das andere
plünderung der plünderung ist lu ting
das ist wenn man köpfe von mobs bekommen
will dann kann man das nehmen und
deswegen würde ich ganz gut sagen dass
sie schlag ist was ist kein fahrzeug
besitzt wird jahren verzauberte das noch
einlagen oder sollte ich feiere
verunsichern
dem schlag da kannst du dich
verunsichert in resse ich will alles
super toll erklärt ja es ist tatsächlich
richtig wobei schön lang als
verzauberung gibt aber nur verbogen
ehrlich was so war fuhr ich dachte schon
ich hätte alles als kommen also man ja
aber ich habe es einfach vom
ausschlussverfahren gemacht deswegen
aber man kann auch bei joker habe ich
noch einen oder anderen im buch offene
axt machen aber das ist vollkommen
schlag ist und sich nur bogen
okay das ist quasi die schärfe des
bogens glaube ich oder stärke oder ist
mir egal
frage 13 sind wir schon es geht um
250.000 diamanten und die frage kommt
von halver lp und sie lautet in welcher
dimension funktioniert der bieten block
nicht also horst feuer und dann
dimensionen oberwelt b c oder d keiner
der drei also das ist quasi in allen
dreien funktioniert was von ner die
ersten drei oberwelt messer ende
doch mal bitte fifty fifty fifty fifty
und übrig bleiben
leser und ende ich hätte echt gedacht
ich hätte am anfang an gesetzlich gesagt
die aber jetzt lepper und ende
ich würde grob sagen ende also in der
oberwelt funktion auf keinen fall dass
de ist auf jeden fall als auch aus jetzt
never oder end ich würde jetzt einfach
ich habe echt keine ahnung wer nie
getestet habe aber ich würde echt
einfach jetzt sagen dem länder
funktioniert aber am ende nicht weil am
ende richtig viel nicht funktioniert ok
ich sage einfach ende
willst du ende einfach einloggen ich lag
ende allen gut wenn du dir dabei so
sicher bist dann muss ich leider ein
wenig enttäuscht nein das ist nicht ganz
so richtig wahrgenommen aber ich hätte
jetzt auch gedacht so weil es internet
jorge hab ich schon flüchtig wie auch
jetzt in angriff und wie sie
angeschrieben weil ich dachte dass ich
so eine komische frage kommt wie viele
leute hast du der box oder so aber
welchen oder sie also und es und y y
okay man weißt du die easy doppelt hh ok
ich angeschrieben
ja das ist der einzige ort online ist ja
scheiße funktioniert im netz im netz
funktioniert ist nicht das ist es ja
gerade dem ende funktioniert es dann
richtig auf das halle ganz einfach stell
dir doch mal den vor oder sind diese
obsidian türme und aus diesen obsidian
tim kommt auch auf stimmen da sind ja
sogar auch ich vollidiot nein ja gut
egal wie viel man damit gewonnen
jetzt muss ich gerade selber überlegen
gab es eine sicherung stufe ja die gab
es damit hast du glücklicherweise noch
65.000 diamanten gewonnen ein voll
packen das jetzt irgendwie 250.000 oder
nein nur 32.000 haha nein
manno regal von 250.000 32.000 okay
richtig so war es nämlich dabei komme
ganz hart dran vorbei hätte kommen
nämlich noch eine frage richtig
beantwortet hätte 32.000 aussicht gehabt
aber bei mir ist es so ich war halt
schon richtig weit oben und bin trotzdem
auf 32.000 und ruhig richtig viel
schlimmer hat es die millionen oder
erhält ist hier immer das fünfzehnte
hier ist es noch
ich bin hier ich bin die kamera eine
million kräfte denn für die zwei monate
dann ist nicht gereicht aber hast du die
einem jahr schon ausgegeben finden und
geld
ja ich alles aufs konto gehackt auch
dich lebt von den sims lado gibst geld
finden um geld aus wer macht das nicht
mehr gleich viel geld für bella logisch
damit ich wurde angestupst mit einem
hallo ja perfekt wie gut dass wir in
keinem aufnahmestelle sind also ja hast
du noch was zu sagen so es hat mich auf
jeden fall gefreut wieder dabei sein zu
dürfen
die fragen waren
anders als letztes mal letzten mal was
echt so sehr viel zu meinem kanal sein
wie viele jobs wie viele leute hast oder
boxen abonnenten hat er unter diesmal
war es echt krass das auch so sachen
dabei wie beispielsweise mit wem es eine
kollabo und alles mögliche das war auf
jeden fall krasser als jetzt zwar nicht
sonst hätte ich ja auch also jetzt mal
ja die 1 million geschafft michi hat ein
bisschen auf das der keinen telefonjoker
benutzt habe
ich denke jetzt auch ich hätte den hätte
ich dann angerufen habe ich hätte immer
angerufen oder stege oder spark aber die
sind alle drei auf beschäftigt und das
hätte dann zehn jahre gedauert bis sie
geantwortet hätten
das wollte ich euch dann auch nicht
zumuten und es ist ganz einfach weiß
warum 1 gegen inter nicht funktioniert
weil der never kein weil der seine decke
hat quasi weil er kein himmel hat ich
hab so blöd nachgedacht und jetzt alle
wieder den kommentaren
du bist so schreibt aber egal ob ich auf
jeden fall gefreut dabei zu sein und
dann macht ihre abschluss wartete ja es
gibt keine großen abfluss worte dann
kein motiv dafür dass er mich gespielt
hat dank an alle leute die fragen
eingesendet haben ihr findet den link
falls ja welche einsehen wollte in der
video beschreibung dann werdet ihr auch
so erwähnt wie der liebe hohlkopf king 1
und ja das war's wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder